of the many dialects of the Arabic
language spoken across the Arab world
the most widely understood is probably
Egyptian Arabic in particular the
variety spoken in Cairo why well Egypt
is by far the most populous Arab country
with 110 million people and Cairo is by
far the largest Arab City with around 22
million people living in its
metropolitan area throughout the 20th
century it was the main center of the
Arab world's movie industry and music
industry this familiarized Arabic
speakers everywhere with the dialect of
Cairo though in the internet era the
Egyptian Arabic of Cairo has become
somewhat less dominant in media it's
still widely understood and is probably
the most popular dialect for Learners of
Arabic